- I was a government major
which mean I had to write a lot of papers.
Now when a normal student writes a paper
they might spread the
work out a little like.
(blows air)
- Man wouldn't it be nice
(phone rings)
hello?
- [male voice on phone] Doctor Mike
- Yes?
- [male voice on phone]
Mikhail Varshavski right?
- Yes, may I ask who's calling?
- [male voice on phone]
Hey Mike, it's TED.
- Ted who?
- [male voice on phone]
TED, did I stutter?
TED conference ideas worth spreading,
talking on stages, smart people stuff.
We're calling to see if you
want to do a speech with us.
- (Whispers) yes yes yes yes!
- [male voice on phone] Doctor Mike, Talk.
- Oh yes, sorry, are you the Ted?
You're the guy that
started the whole thing,
you're Ted?
- [male voice on phone] Good God.
Hey Mike, by name is Bill I work for TED.
TED is an acronym
it stands for Technology and
- Okay okay, say no more Bill
lets make this happen, you
just name the time and place.
(upbeat tropical music)
- Jack, Jack, hold me Jack.
Don't let go Jack.
I'm just kidding.
Guys we are in Monaco and
its time for my TED Talk.
I just almost fell through the roof.
(piano twinkle music)
Alright so I am getting ready
to rehearse my TED Talk.
There's people on stage right now,
you can see that they're
practicing their speeches.
Basically they're asking people
to do one minute of their
speech to do a sound check.
I'm gonna do my intro
and because no one else even
the director of this talk
has heard my speech before,
I'm really excited to give it to them.
(piano twinkle music)
Being such a huge fan
of the TED conference,
to get a call and an invitation
to speak at a conference
was just incredible.
I mean there's so much that I wanna say.
I've been put in this unique situation
where I'm in between medicine
and marketing and YouTube
and all this stuff.
I feel like there's a lot
that I want to tell you guys,
and I think this TED Talk
is gonna be the first step
of you truly understanding
what's inside my mind
when I see what's going on
in the current state of media
and the current state of healthcare.
(piano twinkle music)
Alrighty so,
we just crushed the one
minute opening rehearsal.
Which doesn't say much
cause the speech is gonna be
about ten minutes long.
But what I'm gonna do now
walking back to my hotel from the forum,
I'm gonna practice my speech
right here out in the open
with just a beautiful
Mediterranean Sea as my audience.
(piano twinkle music)
Come 2017 we're say it extends
Alrighty so we just got up,
it's pretty early considering its 5 hours,
6 hours back in New York
but I'm gonna lead all the TEDX speakers
in a morning exercise session
because you know that's what I do.
(happy soft techno music)
And pretend you're swimming.
This is not how you swim
but you can pretend this is how you swim.
(happy soft techno music)
30 seconds, come on you 15 more.
- I don't know, its quite tough.
- What's that over there,
what's that ledge you're working on?
Go a little lower.
There you go.
(happy soft techno music)
20 seconds in, halfway there.
Three, Two, One.
(happy soft techno music)
Have breakfast and then its
time to spread your ideas.
Thanks for coming.
(clapping)
I'm a little out of shape
so it didn't go that well
but we had fun, I think,
and we learned something.
You know, medical stuff.
(happy soft techno music)
Such a nice day, wow.
(happy tropical techno music)
Okay, enough of this.
You hopefully came here
to see my TED Talk.
Well, I hope you did.
So without further ado,
role the tape.
(static)
- I'm delighted to say that
there is a doctor in the house.
Doctor Mike!
(crowd cheers)
- You wake
(phone ringing in static)
Hi, TED?
- [Bill] Hey Mike, it's Bill.
Look you can't play that speech.
- What? It's my speech!
- [Bill] No buddy, it's our speech.
Go ahead and link that bad boy.
- Fine.
Guys just click above.
♪ Birthday to you! ♪
(crowd cheers)
Speech!
Speech yes.
I did mine today!
(upbeat jazz)